hello everybody my name is nine I'm the
black female engineer I provide y'all
with some Tech Career life content and
today yo we are talking about something
I've been talking about for a long time
in like my own circles and that is quiet
quitting because my oh my gone are the
days where I give 110.
percent
[Music]
so what is quiet quitting let's start
there why quitting is kind of what I
just said you no longer are
giving 110 at your job you're not
quitting you're not leaving but while
you're staying you are staying within
the bounds of
your job description you know what I
mean you are mentally letting go
quitting the idea that to be a good
member of society that means killing
yourself for a job during a job I
remember when I worked in finance people
would brag about how many hours they put
in about how they slept at 4am and are
here back at six and that would be like
this token this kind of thing that seems
to have real monetary value but it's
like why did you do that you're getting
paid just the same so like what's that
about but man long gone are those days
at least for me and like some
like-minded people I myself was born
outside of the United States and I
always had the idea that
to succeed in this life that meant going
to school getting a good education and
getting a great job and being the best
employee at that job that is what made
your life worthwhile you know and I
bought into this I really did I remember
I was one of the first of my friends to
get an internship out of college at a
big four accounting firm as a sophomore
do you know like that was pretty like
that was a big deal then the next year I
had an internship at a Big Five bank and
so I spent a good amount with my
adolescents with this idea of for my
life to have any real value it needs to
somehow be tied back to work and what I
do nine to five so what happened what
happened because it seems like that was
the sentiment of a lot of people my age
what happened well
yeah yeah
that happened covid happened
covet happened and everything all of a
sudden just stopped
stop all of a sudden we don't know what
tomorrow looks like I mean like truly
truly I I don't know about you I don't
know maybe you were a doctor in fauci's
office but I didn't know what tomorrow
looked like day by day for like a year a
year and a half and that's terrifying
especially like I am honestly so blessed
that nobody in my family or those I
cared about were directly impacted in a
devastating Way by covid-19 but so many
people in so many families were and so
kovit gave all of us as a society the
opportunity to reflect the opportunity
to sit back and think on what we find
most important in this life because as
it turns out
it's not forever on top of that we are
now seeing that the rewards that once
were offered to the people who worked
hard and picked the extra shift and
worked over time they're no longer here
they have they have disappeared what
rewards for example buying a house
that's a big one that's a big one I
personally have been talking about and
to have been like upset about because
I've always wanted to own a home
yo did you know that right now in 2022
the average home price is four hundred
thousand dollars now depending on where
you are that may not seem crazy but when
you think about how that that is a 30
increase from last year
what that's not sustainable last year
the average home price was a little over
three hundred thousand dollars that
means most people most of America even
if they put in double ships even if they
find a side hustle will not be able to
afford a house anytime truly soon it
wasn't that long ago that Tech
experience one of the biggest layoffs in
the recent years this last spring and
summer so many companies have been
laying off their Tech workers and their
toe teams and departments
and yet you expect me to
hold this company up with such like
admiration and oh 110 no like what so
what does quiet quitting look like in
practice like actually actually what
does it look like I actually I to be
honest I kind of wish it was a different
it was a different name because the idea
of quiet quitting I think it is
what's the word what's the word what's
the what's that word for it's not being
represented correctly like it creates
assumptions that aren't correct to the
name I'm gonna know the word and I know
y'all are yelling at me saying the word
that it is and I cannot think of it
I can't think of the word but to me when
I hear quiet quitting I think of leaving
without telling anybody you know what I
mean I think slowly packing up your
laptop and leaving and just never
showing up again never answering your
phone never answering your email just
never showing up again that's what I
hear when I hear quiet quitting and
that's not what that is it doesn't mean
being a bad worker it doesn't mean
leaving everything and everybody that's
not what quiet quitting means quiet
quitting in practice is doing your job
quiet quitting in practice is not okay
here actually I'll edit that it's not
doing your job it's doing the job you
were hired to do not the job they now
have created because it's been x amount
of months and now like oh here's more
work and more work and more work and oh
but it's your job no that's not the job
I was hired to do with this pay stub of
ten dollars an hour that's not what you
hired me to do I need to calm down I'm
getting revved up I'm getting really
rubbed up here
I get so upset like I seriously get so
upset because like I feel like it's only
corporate where this expectation of
giving your all and receiving pennies
back and receiving just crumbs back is
so wildly it's so widely accepted as
like the correct thing like it gets so
mad because how many times do we tell
our friends do we tell our loved ones
like oh you're putting X Y and Z in the
relationship and you're not getting XYZ
back leave or that's not a good
friendship that's not a good
relationship why the hell are you
staying and yet in corporate we're
expected to do that and if we don't do
that we're a bad word like I get so
annoyed by that but to get back on track
quiet quitting is simply doing the job
you're hired to do if it's said on your
job description or it was understood
between you and your manager that your
job is nine to five why are you showing
up at 8 30 why are you showing up at
eight hell why are you showing up at 8
your job is nine to five be there nine
to five you get a 30 minute lunch be at
lunch for the Whole 30 minutes and don't
answer your phone from your boss from
your manager and everything unless it's
a true true emergency don't like they
can deal without you for 30 more minutes
that is what quiet quitting is no more
no no more of that it's so funny because
I'm thinking about examples where maybe
I was in a company culture that really
drilled into like we must do X Y and Z
above even though you're getting paid
nothing or even if you are getting paid
something it's still not what the
agreement was in terms of hey
we agreed this is the job I would do and
one of the examples I have is I used to
work I I I'll drop the name here I
actually don't care that much I used to
work at ey as an intern and at ey I was
a like tax what was I like an audit
slash tax intern I don't even remember
but they worked my team worked at a
single conference table because they
would have to go to their clients like
the teams would have to go to the client
site a lot of times the clients just had
a big conference room for them to work
at which meant you were working at the
same table as your boss and your manager
and your co-worker and your intern you
all were in this big long table at lunch
everyone would eat their lunch at that
table and like eat their lunch while
like doing work
no even then even at the mere age of 18
years old I was like nah fam like no
that's a big no for me and so I would
get up walk across the room at noon as
you should oh walk across the room get
in my car and go and go somewhere for
lunch sometimes dead dead dead dead
serious sometimes I wouldn't even have
anywhere to go because I brought a lunch
and I would simply go in the car and eat
in my car simply for the piece of it
because
what am I supposed to do I'm like sit in
this conference table and talk to no one
and have no true break it's important in
general to just have a break to have a
moment to breathe and now I can't even
have that oh no you got me messed up if
you think I'm not going to sit in my car
instead of handling being part of this
situation no not at all real quick
please know I'm not saying anything bad
about ey at all I'm just sharing my
experience uh I really liked my team I
really like my manager I mean it was
still it was real I don't work there
anymore uh that's just something to
share because you know transparency and
like it's not that deep and so how can
you implement why quitting in your own
day-to-day in your own nine to five
they'll actually contribute to one a
better life work balance but also just a
better nine to five in general one of my
favorite tips for this is before you get
assigned any extra work let's say you
already are juggling a couple of things
they're all within your job description
but things are just yeah they're
juggling around and you're getting
stressed because yeah deadlines are
coming and it's just a lot now your
major comes in and says hey add this to
the list pretty please and scurries off
instead of just taking that and being
like shoot okay guess I'm gonna have to
put more unpaid hours to complete this
and that really sucks and you know
crying to yourself at your desk about it
instead of just taking that say Hey okay
so you also want this done and there
they'd be like yes so then say okay cool
here are the things I'm currently
working on what exactly and like I'm I
sound passive aggressive right now
because I'm very riled up but this would
not be the passive aggressive way at all
but you'd be like okay cool here are the
things I'm working on right now could
you let me know which things I should
de-prioritize in order to get this done
by the timeline you want
done do you see how easy that is it's
their job as a manager to help you
succeed at your job and asking questions
like these it lets them know okay I'm
juggling X Y and Z right now and I'm the
kind of worker who wants to make sure I
provide you the correct product a good
product even though it's not it may not
be like exceptional because you don't
pay me for that but it's a good product
I care about that which I put off to the
side for the time being in order to get
to the thing that you now want me to
work on that is a more than okay
question and it's also a question that
in the future will help the manager
realize like okay let me make sure that
this person does have the capacity to
accomplish XYZ a code specific example
is making sure that the tickets you
create either create for yourself or
your managers are creating for you make
sure that they are tickets that are
small don't be creating tickets or don't
accept tickets that are create this new
page create a new home screen page that
to me truly truly sounds like at least
10 tickets at least 10 tickets because
we need likely that home screen has a
navigation bar luckily it has some
images it has maybe some animation
effects when you scroll it has a footer
it has a contact me section it has all
of these different things so you need to
create tickets for each single chunk
there this is so important for so many
different reasons not just the quiet
quitting part of things but also just
productivity because instead of spending
x amount of days or weeks on this big
thing and having to say to your boss
every single day like oh I'm still
working on it I'm still working on it
and there's really no nothing for them
to see that you've accomplished now
every day or every other day you come to
them with a completed task you did the
nav bar you did the body you did the
contact me section you did all of these
different things and now you your
co-workers and your boss all recognize
that progress is being made rather than
simply relying on your word because
everything had been previously put in
just one ticket which is going to take
weeks to accomplish so when things are
in one ticket like that it also creates
this heightened sense of urgency and we
again don't want that and just quiet
quitting era we don't want this false
sense of things need to be done
yesterday we don't want that let's allow
work to be the thing that supplements
the life we want to live not what
hinders it okay y'all and I hope it's
very clear that again I'm not advocating
being a bad worker I'm advocating you
doing the job you are hired to do and
getting paid for the job you are hired
to do but yeah that's it y'all let me
know what y'all think Below have you
heard about quiet quitting is this the
first time what are your thoughts and
let's just chat so thanks y'all for
being here and I'll see you next week
bye